hey cheese bags I'm Kevin hi I'm Lauren
hey I'm Jason
hey I'm Brett hi I'm Kiran hi I'm
Stephanie and today we're gonna be
drawing Disney Villains from memory hey
and be sure to stick around to the end
of the video to find out how you can
enter for a chance to win this Wacom
Intuos tablet courtesy of our good
friends at Walker today you'll be
drawing haiti's oh okay he's fire today
you'll be drawing Cruella de Vil today
you'll be drawing Ursula okay all right
okay I see that you're outside yeah I
miss outside you know I could be out
here how have you been since the last
draw-off
Brent not too bad you know yeah man I
was rocking the castaway beard for a
while when I started getting cabin fever
and then I shaved off all my all my
beautiful hair which is half the reason
I'm wearing a baseball cap
check out that beard that luscious beer
yeah yeah so Lorne you are a character
designer yes what is your general
approach to character design like what
makes a good character for you for me it
comes down to kind of conveying the
characters traits in their design also
the shape language is very important
okay
I remember particularly of course her
black and white split hair mm-hmm and
what's cool about her is like she looks
like she's kind of like a big lady but
really she's like a super Twiggy skinny
lady just an amine coat okay so first
question does Ursula have ears I think
she knows really beats okay I'm gonna
give her ears and then if I'm wrong then
I'm gonna blame you like what do you
what is it what am I gonna do with his
legs so I just drawing
oh he's wearing he's wearing like a long
a long time Tony that yeah I need to
draw the legs trunk okay she's super
angular which is like
see unlike a like a female character
yeah I've always I really like her high
cheekbones or her very angry expressions
too although I might go a little softer
with with mine mine is coming out kind
of like sensual oh well she's that too
you know I mean she's wearing the coats
for somebody Lauren how you doing I
think I'm doing all right I'm just
trying to remember
kind of like her shape yeah yeah it's
like I know that she's very round yes
but I don't know if I'm making her round
in the right places in fact I'm looking
at it now and I'm like I'm giving her
like linebacker shoulders which I don't
think she has she is so evil she doesn't
sing a song about herself
other people say yeah now I have to just
remember what his like it's a pointy
nose right yes she never slender nose
right I'm like making it pointy yeah
that yeah I'm doing that too okay good
does she have a mole I think she does I
think she does have a mole okay nice
remember one of the things I really
liked about this character was the I'm
drying it now the the cigarette holder
oh yeah that scene where she confronts
some Anita and it's just like this
disgusting green smoke everywhere I hope
I'm not getting her too much booty but I
think you give her as much booty as you
want you know I think the audience can
take it thank you cheese bags at home
can handle some booty does he have like
a widow's peak uh oh yeah I guess his
buyer sort of does behave just like hair
right yeah she has tentacles her legs
right yeah she doesn't have human legs
okay there's a part of her design that
I'm remembering she has but I don't
remember how its implemented and it's
like these little tails
I do remember that really a leak where
they on the back of the coat we're gonna
remember uh she definitely had those
like like on the belt hem kind of
leaving like her I think it is as an
homage and I think that she have this
that she had a purse that was also made
of pails I think so
does he he's not like eyebrows probably
yeah I think so
alright Lauren let's talk color she is
like bluish grayish and her clothes are
black right yes because she's evil we
decided to blue right
sickly blue color I think he's blue I'm
I'm almost positive he's like multiple
shades of blue and gray she she has a
necklace it's like a seashell that she
used to take Ariel's oh no what really I
don't have time to put that in I miss
that I like when characters blow his
flames out and he's decipher what
happened so for my final touches I'm
just finishing up the coloring on her
coat and figuring out these legs
boy how about you
so my finishing touches I am currently
filling in the skin gonna do my really
quick shading pass and then should be
done alright pens down so this is not
Hades but it is someone it is someone uh
it doesn't look Disney style but it it's
definitely karela de Vil and I'm I'm
happy with that
Brenda how do you think he did not too
shabby
I think the colors are there
I think his outfit is he looks like he's
graduating from something it's not got
like a graduation going on so Brent we
obviously can't switch so why don't you
just send me your drawing
oh wow I think you caught him way more
than I did
that nose is long going down yes yours
has a little little Pinocchio nose yeah
we both captured some little gremlin
aspect to him some control he looks like
a troll eyebrows that's one thing I
forgot I never asked you as like oh yeah
this is beautiful look at this I love
all the curves in this I love the curve
of her shoulder I love the curve of her
arm into her back and you know what I
like the curve of her booty oh thank you
that is that weird to say your eyes are
so charming I love her big smile I love
how you interpreted her like hey I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go out on a limb and
say that I think I got her hair color
right I don't think she has gray hair I
think I think you did as well looking at
it it just makes that woo oh my god
you're this beautiful yours is so evil I
love okay I love that the black side is
crazier than the white side of the hair
that was that's really smart
oh thank you this looks like a great
like if I knew that there is like 101
television show but like this looks like
the television version of Cruella De Vil
I think that's what I love the way you
drew it kind of looks like like a
fashion like clothes fashion drawings
the designers do it yeah I definitely
she definitely has the length and you
can put the volume on her so oh yeah
then that long chin and the cloak design
yeah oh yes like he is massive yeah
also he's got like huge forearms yeah
ripped in the forearms these ribs ashes
oh I didn't even realize she had like a
big poof up at the top I remembered it
enough to put it in mine but I don't
know the sleeves being so I forgot that
their sleeves oh I forgot that she wore
like red gloves but you were right about
the purse the tail yeah she's even
skinnier than how he drew her he's
skinny
all right Lauren I owe you an apology
she does have gray hair here's what you
did didn't look wrong though I'm like
okay thank you for that that's a very
kind of you to say but you were right
and I was wrong I'll be putting it out
there and you even got the under spite
of her typical the color purple yeah I
remember that but I I made her entire
tentacle purple she is amazing and even
feel like you just think about her she
is like one of the baddest Disney this
is true she is the baddest anything yeah
I'm thinking like I don't think there's
anybody hopefully we we stand a queen
Lauren yes I stand Ursula we stand a
queen okay so to find out how you can
enter for a chance to win this walk them
into a tablet all you have to do is go
to draw off on Instagram that's at draw
off show find this post and follow the
instructions that's a lot to you
[Music]